Hoy una de las cuestiones que vamos a tratar en este siempre picadito y variadito Q&A
es el equipo que tiene mejor banquillo de la Liga Española.
¿Qué pasa? Pizzarritas, ya es viernes, por fin ya es viernes y estamos aquí en Pizzarritas, claro,
donde si no para hacer un Q&A variadito y picadito con Adrián Blanco,
Alex de Llano y Naguel Miranda. ¿Qué tal chicos? ¿Cómo estáis? Muy buenas. Aquí estamos. Ya os veo
elegantes, no tanto a Adrián Blanco, la verdad, no le veo... Espérate, espérate. Yo... Es... Anclando ya,
minuto uno. Temporada, temporada de bodas, bautizos y comuniones. Así que el bebé en el bautizo,
el novio en la boda y el chaval o la chavala haciendo la comunión que se pongan los calcetines.
Bien, bien, bien. La barra de Toni Kroos. Bien, bien, bien. Los he dejado así porque ponermelos y enseñar la pierna creo que no tocaba.
Bueno, bueno. Vuelves a por otra. Yo creo que enseñar tu pierna, vista la pierna que estás sacando, podría darnos...
Y más ahora con la laser, que me está sacando la pierna. Pfff. Precioso. Sí, sí. Ha venido Adrián Blanco con el niño.
Ayer o antes de ayer en San Jordi vino mucha novia de pizarrita, un tanto harta y frustrada con nosotros
porque hay muchos pizarritas, sobre todo los directores de Champions, que claro, nos ven para
para dormir ya en la cama. Y claro, igual la muchacha quiere leer, quiere ver sus cosas o quiere dormir.
Y tienes ahí al pibardo de turno molestándola. Entonces enseñar la pierna de Adrián Blanco igual podría ser...
Puede aunar, puede aunar. Claro, un buen quid pro quo en este caso en este caso concreto. En todo caso, más allá de los calcetines
En cambio de Adrián Blanco tenemos sudaderas, tenemos camisetones, este tipo de camiseta.
A ver, aquí en cámara, date la vuelta, Nau. Es que está armado por detrás.
A ver, al público. Ahí está. Suba un poquito, Nau. Muy guapa.
Un poquito, Nau. Que no escucho. O sea, para girarme tengo que dejar de escuchar. Ya está.
El pase de modelos hasta aquí. Oye, pero como Gambea está siempre con nosotros en nuestras vidas, seguro que hay más oportunidades.
Hay que decir que Gambea también hace calzoncillos.
Oye, me han llamado.
Para esa promo todavía queda, en todo caso, tenéis un 10% pizarritas con el código pizarritas10 para esos calcetines, las sudaderas, las camisetas o ese calzoncillo que...
En una primera cita no falla.
Alex, ¿cómo va lo tuyo?
A mí, a mí no me agito nadie. También no me hago nada, ni nada.
Uy, uy, uy.
Uy, ya está.
Aprovecha, aprovecha ahora.
Que enfadica, que enfadica.
Bueno, vamos con la primera cuestión. Es una cuestión...
A ver, lleva un por qué con tilde. O sea, es una pregunta, pero más bien es...
Es un maqueja al aire, no es un...
Un descaogo, ¿no?
Sí, sí, sí, totalmente. Es de Truvio2219. Hemos sacado las preguntas esta vez de la pestaña comunidad en YouTube.
¿Por qué la Real no juega ni a las tabas? Explícamelo, por favor, que ya estoy desesperado.
Si alguien se atreve a dar una respuesta cortita, adelante, porque me parece una cuestión muy compleja.
Sí, a ver, yo creo que es una cuestión que no se explica únicamente desde lo futbolístico.
Es decir, no creo que sea una cuestión de pizarra para que analicemos nosotros aquí, porque el sistema Dima no la dejó de funcionar.
Yo creo que hay algo ahí que se ha roto, que se ha erosionado, como queramos decirlo,
pero por eso la Real creo que está compitiendo peor de lo que esperábamos en esta recta final.
Yo estuve viendo con atención la segunda parte del partido entre Alaves y Real Sociedad,
y pese a que estaba Brais Mendes en el campo, pese a haber visto a un equipo que por el once
podía ser más o menos reconocible, con Pablo Marín, que cada vez que tiene cosas positivas,
se notaba que el equipo estaba muy perdido a nivel futbolístico, y en lo que comenta Adri,
que yo creo que es una tendencia que viene repitiendo toda la temporada, pero en lo futbolístico,
es un equipo que no se encuentra, que el pasa dentro no aparece, que tiene muy pocas posibilidades de sorprender.
En la primera parte, lo dice Manolo, además en rueda de prensa, que la Real no había aprovechado sus momentos,
y el Alaves sí que lo hizo con ese gol de Tenale, la desatención de Javi López,
pero es que en la primera parte, que la Real está algo mejor, la Real creo que son cuatro disparos,
no a puerta, cuatro disparos en total, entonces claro, si en tus momentos de superioridad,
lo que generas son cuatro disparos y esos disparos no los ejecuta Haaland, no los ejecuta Robert Lewandowski,
sino que los ejecutan futbolistas que pueden tener gol, pero que no son un seguro de vida, es que claro...
Pues un disparate, ¿no?
Pues sí, pues sí. Al final, yo creo que hay una cuestión táctica de que ciertos perfiles no han funcionado,
otros se te han caído, Miquel Merino era el suelo competitivo de la Real, las ausencias de Martín Zubimendi
se notan un montón, la defensa contra la Real es, por ejemplo, muy joven, Aguer en esta segunda vuelta
creo que ha portado menos que en la primera, o sea, hay un montón de factores futbolísticos,
pero yo estoy de acuerdo, Anahuel, que aquí ya hay un tema de erosión de mensaje de un vestuario que ha cambiado,
quizás ya no tiene tantos soldados Imanol en el batallón, porque muchos se han ido, han llegado otros que, bueno,
no le deben nada a Imanol, no sé si me explico, al final un jugador que Imanol ha sacado desde abajo,
pues le debe cierta cuestión, Susik, por decir uno, o Zaharian, Imanol en concreto no le deben demasiado,
entonces yo creo que eso se puede notar en un equipo que esa era su gran virtud, Anahuel,
que era un equipo muy compacto, muy uniforme, que iban todos a una y que lograban mejorarse el uno al otro,
y ahora mismo no lo hacen.
Es que incluso hay un cambio en el discurso público de Imanol, que después de perder en Vitoria,
diga Imanol, bueno, pues es que a veces se gana y a veces se pierde, esto es impensable hace un año,
yo creo que él no está muy conforme con el tema del libro nuevo que abre la Real Sociedad,
del dar un paso atrás, el rebajar las expectativas, porque yo creo que ese grupo,
por la manera que Imanol lo había llevado, estaba basado en una competencia interna bestial,
que quedan realmente en una guerra, claro, cuando tú le rebajas ambición al proyecto,
yo creo que Imanol no ha sabido acompasar el discurso de manera interna y dar la sensación de que está resignado en los últimos meses.
Es que la Real Nahuel...
Quiero dar una partida a eso que se pierdan entre todo lo demás.
La Real Nahuel tiene ese lema, porque lo ha dicho muchas veces Joaquín Aperriba y lo ha repetido
Roberto Lavelo, Imanol Aguaziz y lo repitan futbolistas, la Real pretende ser del lunes a viernes el mejor equipo de Europa
y esto no se refiere sólo a energía o intensidad, claro, sí, que no es el caso,
sino no se refiere sólo a energía e intensidad en los entrenamientos, que también,
que también, o sea, hemos hablado con muchos jugadores de la Real que nos han explicado que cada partido,
por ejemplo, elogiaban a Silva en ese sentido, que David Silva era un tío que dices, hombre,
en los entrenamientos se tiene que guardar, porque es el crack, porque va a jugar y por lo visto Silva iba con todo
y se mataba a perder, pero también se refería a los campos de entrenamiento, a Zubieta, a la metodología,
a una serie de cuestiones. Yo no sé si aquí esa no renovación de Imanol, ese ya veremos,
esa especie de hórdago, que no sé si es solamente de Imanol con el club, del club con Imanol,
de Imanol al público, al vestuario, no sé, es bastante extraño, creo que le está empezando a jugar en contra,
ya había una situación de inestabilidad, que es la primera vez que la vemos en el proyecto Imanol Alguacil,
o el proyecto, si lo queremos llamar, Roberto Lave, en la Real Sociedad Moderna, era una balsa de aceite,
con sus pequeñas subidas o importantes subidas y sus pequeñas bajadas, pero ahora mismo se está comportando
como un club que de lunes a viernes no es el mejor, no sé si me estoy explicando.
También es verdad que hay que decir que es de agradecer que para la Real Sociedad que esta caída
sea que todavía puede luchar por puestos europeos, que sí que es verdad que obviamente que en las últimas jornadas
está dejando bastante que desear, pero que en otras épocas hubiera supuesto una pelea por no bajar,
o incluso un descenso.
Sí, pero fíjate, Álex, que por eso mismo creo que sería lo mejor para las dos partes que se anunciase ya,
cuanto antes, para que ese vestuario tenga el aliciente de tratar de matar ya en esta recta final,
porque Imanol se va a marchar y porque se va a abrir otro capítulo el verano que ve.
Veremos ahora y derby vasco, el Athletic Club ganó a la Unión Deportiva de Las Palmas y prácticamente
sello a la Champions, es verdad que tiene la Europa League, no sé cómo se va a tomar el derby,
pero cuidado, que sabemos que un derby lo potencia todo y puede marcar puntos de inflexión también positivos,
ojo, no tiene tan lejos Europa a la Real Sociedad, pero es verdad que yo pensaba que iba a quedar séptimo directamente.
Fíjate la que se lió en el derby de la primera vuelta, por ejemplo, con las regalaciones de Ollar Zábal.
Es verdad, sí, fue la primera muestra.
Ya hay ambiente de previa derby.
La primera muestra de una pequeña disensión, Miquelo Ollar Zábal y Manuel Guacil,
que luego Imanol Guacil dijo que no, que el problema era los periodistas, que lo habíamos entendido mal,
bueno, esto es lo de siempre, el problema siempre es el cartero o el mensajero,
pero sí que es verdad que en ese derby pasaron cositas.
Segunda cuestión de Marcos Corral Faba.
Viendo el nivel de Joan García, ¿creéis que es el jugador de la Liga que más diferencia hay entre su nivel
y el segundo mejor jugador de su equipo, que entiendo yo que sería Javi Pugado, al menos a nivel diferencial?
Yo creo que sí, pero bueno, da igual.
Vamos a buscar otros casos.
Claro, es que pregunta, es que pregunta, Anabuela, además, aparte de esta Liga,
si recordamos algún caso histórico en este sentido de un jugador que destaca tantísimo sobre su equipo,
que aquí siempre hemos dicho, hemos hablado mucho de Yago Aspas en el Celta,
yo recuerdo Gerard Moreno también en el español en este sentido, carrilear mucho al conjunto periquito,
pero es verdad que ahora mismo entre Joan García y el segundo, sea quien sea, yo creo que hay dos escalones.
Sí, sí, sí.
¿Ha haber otros casos?
Claro, estoy pensando, de esta Liga, porque de esta Liga se me ocurre, por ejemplo, Budi Mirenos Asuna,
pero creo que está un poco mejor acompañado.
Raúl Moro.
Sí, pero el nivel más alto, o sea, igual aquí se hace por lo bajo, ¿no?
Sí, claro, Raúl Moro está en el primer piso, lo verdad es que el resto está en el subsuelo.
Claro, porque por ejemplo el año deportivo de Las Palmas, Fabio Silvatina Moleiro y viceversa,
no sé si algún año del Atletic con Aduriz podría entrar, pero creo que no.
Raba en el Leganer.
Uff, tampoco...
Yago estaba muy bien repartida a esta clase media, ¿no?
Es que al final con Joan García estamos hablando de que es uno de los jugadores de la Liga,
o sea, es que para mí si hacemos un top 10 está Joan García, es que, pero no por poner un portero.
Igual un top 5, ¿eh? Igual un top 5.
Bueno, hace unas temporadas, de hecho antes del último descenso del Girona, Estuani,
sí, sí, sí, sí, sí, sí.
Puedo estar, sí.
Mira, os digo uno, que igual me compráis.
A ver.
Sugaardó di Luquevacchio?
Sí, sí, sí.
Lo más cercano, lo más cercano.
Sí, sí, bueno, sí, con Badé, ¿no?
Sí, seguramente con...
Se verá que Badé anda a Flamenco, pero sí.
Nunca mejor dicho.
Nunca mejor dicho ¿por qué?
Amo cada por su... vale, vale, digo...
Digo, tira, tira, tira aquí.
No, no, no.
El triple.
Iba por la nacionalidad de Badé, digo, pero ¿qué dice?
No, no nos intercambiemos los roles.
No somos la típica película en la que nos dormimos y yo soy la suegra y tú eres Quintana, el repeinado.
O sea, no puede ser, ¿eh?
Pero la respuesta a cada uno es brutal, ¿eh?
Pensé que lo decías por la nacionalidad.
Sí, sí, sí, ha ido más allá.
Hemos empezado hablando de Luque Bakia y tal y digo...
No, no, no.
...que era Bakia un triple que no tocaba.
No sé si Murichi en algún año de Javier Aguirre...
Hace dos temporadas.
Griezmann en el Atlético de Madrid.
Podría ser.
Bueno, a nivel histórico, ¿recordáis alguna otra cosa respecto a la...
o más allá de la que he comentado esta de Iago Aspas que yo creo que era muy notoria?
La fita.
La fita de las últimas jornadas.
Sí, sí.
Chupete suazo en el Zaragoza, ¿eh?
Chupete suazo.
Pero aquel Zaragoza tenía más cositas aparte del Chupete.
Sí, tenía armas, tenía armas, sí, sí, sí.
Es que claro, aparte hemos sido muy dados a tener en la Liga como parejas.
Estaba pensando en el Rossi Nilmar, por ejemplo,
como se lesiona a los dos, el Villarreal se acaba yendo a segunda.
Y es que además en este concepto,
chicos, es que no podemos buscar un Villarreal, un Madrid-Barça.
Claro, tienes que tener un equipo de abajo.
Tienes que tener un equipo de abajo o de zona media capaz de tener a un jugador,
insisto, con Joan García no estamos hablando de que es un jugador de zona europea.
Estamos hablando de que igual lo ficha el Arsenal y se lo plantea para sustituir a Rayas.
Igual se interesa, bueno, parecía el Barcelona y puede ser su portero.
Estamos hablando de eso, estamos hablando de semifinalistas de Champions.
Tengo uno, tengo uno.
Tengo uno, tengo uno, sin salir del propio Real Club Deportivo Español,
Darder hace dos temporadas.
Puede ser, eh.
Estaba José Lu.
Sí.
Pero el equipo tiene ese tramo de temporada.
José Lu es al revés que la fita.
Las últimas jornadas fue el peor jugador de...
Sí, sí, sí.
Bueno, es una...
Es una Miramilla en el Elche.
Es una cosa muy complicada.
Es muy difícil esta categoría, eh.
Es que Falcao, por ejemplo, tenía a Godín.
Claro, claro.
Tenía a Courtois.
Es que claro, yo insisto que de los de arriba me parece muy complicado.
En todo caso es un buen reto para nuestros pitaladitas.
¿Jona también a las Palmas?
¿Cómo?
Las Palmas que baja, puede ser.
Puede ser, puede ser.
Kevin Prince-Wateng, ¿no?
Sí.
Claro, lo que pasa es que las Palmas que baja hace 22 puntos.
Y también hay a Tanaoussou por las noches.
¡Uy! Tana.
Que es verdad que allí hay mucho nivel,
pero creo que Tana estábamos hablando de...
de un auténtico jugador diferencial.
Para nivel por las noches,
es el de Araujo, ¿no?
El que era canterano de Boca Juniors.
Sí, sí, sí.
Sí, Julián no.
Bueno, no sabemos.
Bueno, no sabemos, pero...
En algún momento puede llegar.
El chino.
Sí, sí, sí.
Es un buen reto para nuestros pizarritas.
Recordad alguna pareja...
No, pareja no, perdón.
Algún jugador histórico que estuviese tan separado
del segundo como Joan García lo está,
insisto, de Javi Pugado.
No sé si podría ser Maras Cumbula
también uno de ese nivel
de segundo posición en español.
Pero bueno,
se te había ocurrido uno, ¿no, Nahuel?
Sí, sí. Temporal 17-18.
Estaba mirando Máximus Galeadores y tal,
si me inspiraba.
Claro, el top tres son Messi, Cristiano y Suárez.
Luego cuartos, Lago Aspas,
con 22 goles, pero es que Máximus Galeadores
mete 17.
Máximus Galeadores mete más goles que Nahuel Bale.
No, no, no, pero es que igual
los 17 goles de Máximus Galeadores hay que imputárselos
también a Lago Aspas.
Creo que la temporada del chatín
de que si no estaba Lago Aspas...
Es la siguiente.
Creo que es la siguiente, sí. Y el que sí que marca 21 goles
aquella temporada y está muy solito
es Stuanicon21
por tu marca 11, que es el segundo
máximo goleador del Girona.
Yo tengo una que es una
fricada brutal,
que es Polster en el Logroñés.
Ah, bueno,
sí, sí. Yo no lo viví,
pero hablan de eso, de un crack
en un equipo que
termina bajando. A más, creo que con...
No baja, en este...
Ah, vale, vale, vale.
Marca 14, que justo lo tengo delante.
Marca 14 goles, los mismos goles que Butragueño, por ejemplo.
Uno menos que Tizzi.
El español tiene otro bueno, que es
Sergio García.
Sí. Sergio García había temporada
donde estaba muy por encima del equipo.
También carrileando...
Xtandr0n en el Málaga.
Pero Sergio coincide con
Stuani, ¿no? Eran los dos...
Estaban en el español,
estaban en el español...
Juega en banda, jugaba en banda.
Juega en banda con... Con la máscara.
Bueno, queremos nombres
pizarritas, así que dejándonos en comentarios.
Nosotros nos vamos a poner a hablar
de Jauré Wizard.
Porque Robert Puen
pregunta ¿qué opináis sobre la temporada
de Jauré Wizard?
Como se le llama aquí, jugador intenso,
puro pulmón y de los que más me va a recuperar
en campo rival.
En 2020 jugaba en el
Vermeo en tercera división.
A mí es que me parece
tremendamente completo.
Está bien destacar su pulmón, su intensidad,
su capacidad para recuperar. Creo que sólo estaba
por detrás de Pedri. Y ahora mismo por detrás de Pedri
están todos. Así que no es decir
prácticamente nada.
Pero es que luego con pelota me parece aseada.
Me parece que es un jugador que incluso tiene su llegada.
O sea, no le veo
ningún defecto marcado. Y esto
me parece interesantísimo para un Atleti Club
de Ernesto Valverde, que
al final es un equipo muy intenso, muy enérgico,
que le mete mucho ritmo a Adri,
pero que también tiene jugadores de buenísimo
pie. Hay que pensar en Galaxy o en Sunset.
Que esa pareja
a la reta de Jauré Guizar
le está dando mucho a Atleti Club por lo que hacen
con la pelota, también sin ella
por el desparpajo que además
tiene Jauré Guizar, que con balón se atreve a
hacer bastantes cosas. Yo esta temporada de Jauré Guizar
es la que esperaba de Jad Frados.
Pensaba que iba a ser esto de Jad. Que iba a dar este paso
al frente y se iba a sentar en el
doble pibote. Pero
no, para mí fue uno de los
nombres propios en cuanto a Revelación
de la temporada. A mí hay una cosa que me alucina
de él, que es su lectura
de lo que va a ocurrir, del siguiente
movimiento que va a ocurrir.
Porque se posiciona realmente
bien. Eso es. Yo creo que muchas de esas recuperaciones
que hace en campo rival, no
son tanto por la energía que también,
sino por la lectura que hace de lo que
puede ocurrir. Y la verdad que es un futbolista
magnífico y que en vivo
te conquista y que desde luego, bueno,
es que me parece que es uno de los talentos
de este año en la Liga y que ojalá
podamos ver pronto la selección porque creo
que tiene muchas de las condiciones que
ese tipo de interior
de la selección española podría tener.
Sí, a ver, mola una valoridad.
Y creo que le ha hecho al
Athletic depender un poco menos de galarreta.
Que me parece una de las debilidades
de la plantilla y bueno, cuando
juegan los dos la verdad es que da gusto
verlos. Había alguna duda yo creo en otras temporadas
con el doble pibote de la Athletic Club, pero es de que
Howrieizer se asienta
que todas despejadas.
Es que mira que a mí, Michael
Besgat es un jugador que me gusta más que la mayoría,
pero hubo momentos del
Michael Besgat, Dani García,
ostras, es que se quedaba muy
corto precisamente en ataque
posicional. En todo lo que no fuese ir
arriba y recuperar, la Athletic Club
se quedaba muy corto y era el tipo de partido que se
atragantaba a la Athletic Club.
Cuarta cuestión de Edu3116.
¿Creéis que el caso de
Olmo puede ser similar al de Pedri
con las lesiones? Sabemos que es
muy bueno, pero con regularidad se convierte en una
bomba de jugador o que ya
con Olmo no hay más por descubrir.
A ver,
aquí a Pedri se le hizo un estudio
genético para el tema de las lesiones.
Desconozco
en profundidad, bueno,
en profundidad y a nivel superficial.
¿Qué significa esto y qué implicación tiene luego
en el día a día? Entiendo yo
que un mayor conocimiento a nivel de cargas,
de trabajo físico y demás, de preparación,
de cuidados posteriores,
pues le permite ser más adaptativo
al físico, al médico,
al preparador. Incluso a alimentación,
entiendo, ¿no? Que debería ir metido también.
Puede ser. También se le ha hecho a Olmo,
así que vamos a ver qué resultados puede dar en el
medio plazo, pero sí que es verdad
que yo tengo clarísimo, Álex, que lo único que
frenada ni Olmo, no del
nivel de Pedri, que ahora mismo estamos hablando de palabras
mayores, pero de sí, de ser
un futbolista exageradamente
bueno, es las
lesiones. O sea, es que no creo que le
salte otra cosa en su fútbol.
Tal cual. Estamos viendo un
futbolista que cuando está en el campo, el Barça
tiene una versión muy diferente, una versión
mucho más alegre y que yo creo
que permite a otros intérpretes incluso
alcanzar un mejor nivel,
pero sí que desde luego, por ejemplo, es un
gran what if, ¿no? Que hubiera ocurrido
en la selección española, por ejemplo, si no hubiera
caído en ciertos momentos, incluso en la
temporada del Barça. A mí me parece que es
una mala fortuna, ¿no? Ahí lo que está teniendo
Aniolmo, pero desde luego, bueno, que
consigue con ese estudio, si consigue
ir, yo creo que el Barça, entendiendo mejor
el cuerpo de Aniolmo, vamos a tener un
Aniolmo fuerte y que yo creo que a partir de ahí
sí que le podemos hablar para otro tipo de
cosas, para lograr otro tipo de cosas.
Pues sí, ojalá den con la tecla y si dan
con la tecla, con Aniolmo, que
le hagan después el estudio a Sam Zed, porque es otro
que también a nivel físico
sufre una barbaridad.
Es una respuesta de hacer de punto
evidente, ¿no? Quiere decir,
oye, pues ya sí, jugando cuatro grados,
me muestra que es bueno, si tuviera más continuidad, pues
creo que tiraría para adelante, no hay mucha
discusión. ¿Pero tú crees que sería tan exagerado
como con Pedri?
Vamos, estoy convencido, para un futbolista
es comunal, pero va a
tener, o ha tenido siempre
ese asterisco. Es que yo
no he podido evitar, por cierto,
seguir dándole vueltas a la pregunta anterior, ¿eh?
He caído en Alberto Bueno en el Rayo, 17
goles,
y me he acordado de
el levante de Caicedo,
Martins y Babá de Aguara, ¿eh?
Por tras, chaval.
Sobre todo Martins, daba una sensación de
y Caicedo,
que estaba ahí un poquito al trá y era
muy, ni Villa, ni Agüero, Felipe
Caicedo, ¿eh? Cuidado ahí con Ballesteros
y con Barquero, que también
jugaban, incluso tenía una tez para Baldo,
que cuidado. Lo de Daniel
Olmo y Pedri, yo marcaría una diferencia, y es
que me parece muy importante, por si
no le sale bien el tema de Daniel Olmo.
Pedri no estaba pudiendo jugar
a un buen nivel cuando se recuperaba.
Olmo, cuando se recupera,
recupera su nivel muy rápidamente.
Pero Pedri no se lesionaba
tanto. Llega un momento
que es un problema, pero es que yo a Olmo siempre
le recuerdo con lesiones. Sí, sí, sí,
por temporada tiene dos o tres, es que esto es
así, pero
el tema es que las lesiones llegan a
minar moralmente a
Adri, que emocionalmente
ha estado... Pero esto me recuerda
a Adrian Robben, a mí me flipaba
porque se lesionaba una
barbaridad. De hecho se lesiona también el primer
año en el Bayern, luego ya mejora,
pero es que cuando volvía
estaba fantástico.
Es lo de Daniel Olmo.
Pedri cuando volvía, me parecía
que le costaba mucho.
Yo creo que claro, si siga así va a haber un momento en el que
Olmo, ostras,
puede caer.
Esta temporada ha estado
según Transfer Max, 71 días lesionados,
se ha perdido 20 partidos.
Según Transfer Max,
la temporada pasada, 114 días
lesionados, se ha perdido
25 partidos.
Y vamos, es que en todas las últimas
cuatro temporadas se ha perdido de mínimo
70 días de competición.
Sí, sí, es que son demasiado
problemas. Si mereces otro,
quedé con la tecla, por cierto.
Sí, sí, sí, parece.
Parece, parece.
Juan Francisco Fugliana
pregunta. Ojo, ¿eh?
A ver. ¿Creéis que
ante Budimir está sobrevalorado?
La mitad de sus goles son
penaltis.
Yo creo que no. Yo creo que no, pero
pero tampoco
es un futbolista el que iría a fichar.
Me parece que está muy bien
para Osasuna y creo que
vamos, que tiene que ser el jugador franquicio
a Osasuna. Yo creo que de esto hay pocas dudas.
Pero no veo, o sea,
creo que si vas a por Budimir
tendrías a sobrepagar por el tema de las cifras.
En eso estoy de acuerdo.
Yo creo que depende
mucho del contexto del equipo que seas.
Es decir, si quieres,
si eres un equipo
de abajo media
tabla que quieres aspiraciones más altas,
para mí ante Budimir es una garantía.
O sea, primero sabes. Pero eso no tiene
que ver con el nivel de Budimir, no, sino con
el acomodo que le encuentres. Bueno, con el
acomodo que le puedes encontrar a un tío que cuando
le cae el balón en el área, generalmente,
tenemos todos el recuerdo del de Leganés,
pero generalmente la pelota va a terminar
dentro. O sea, un remate que a veces te lo puede meter,
el propio disparo
de penalti que a veces yo creo que lo veíamos
y demás. Yo es que aquí,
Alex, además, metería
un matiz
importante a la pregunta de Juan Francisco.
Budimir ha marcado ocho penaltis,
los ocho que ha tirado.
Ha provocado seis de ellos. Quiero decir,
no es
que se los estén haciendo, yo que sé, al extremo
de turno o en el balón parado.
Es que es el mismo el que genera esas situaciones
porque es un jugador muy
condicionante en el área, muy listo,
es muy capaz siempre de poner el
cuerpo entre balón y jugador, poner
incluso el pie. Si es típico
penalti que hacen porque intenta
despejar uno, Budimir siempre
se adelanta. Que yo creo que eso también tiene un puntito
de forzarlo, de ser listo
y meter el pie porque sabes, intuyes
que va a meter ahí el pie el defensor.
Es verdad que en Budimir
con la edad que tiene y tal,
pues claro, pero si Budimir tuviese
23-24 años,
es que estamos recordando lo que se
pagó por Maxi
o lo que se paga por jugadores de este estilo.
Es verdad que no es el delantero más moderno del mundo,
de acuerdo,
pero al mismo tiempo este delantero Adri
jamás pasa de moda porque es que
necesita tan poquito para marcar
gol que nunca es innecesario.
De hecho iba a decir que me parece
que está en el lugar ideal, parece que
caja muy bien con la idiosincrasia, además
de Club Atlético de Asuna.
Me parece perfil, primer
espada de un equipo con aspiración europea
y me parecería un recurso muy interesante
por el perfil que tiene para un equipo que
está habitualmente en Europa. Como recurso
es del banquillo, el look de John del Barça,
cuidado, eh, el José Ludo del Madrid,
el José Ludo del Madrid, el Sorlo
del Atleti, estoy de acuerdo.
Budi podría hacer esto. Mira, solo
Levantoski en vape rematan más que él
en el área, en el área de penalti,
la verdad que, a ver, solo
ha marcado todos sus goles en
el área y eso obviamente estamos hablando
de ese tipo de delantero que
te va a dar mucho si es capaz tú de darle
mucho. Yo creo que Asuna esta temporada
por tramos, igual no ha sido capaz de darle
todo lo que a Vante Budi
y mi le puedes dar, pero aún así yo creo
que es el delantero, vamos. Claro, es que Alex.
Yo sí estoy en una dirección deportiva
de un equipo, pues eso, que quiero tener
aspiraciones europeas y tal y tengo
Vante Budi Mil en momento final de
contrato, vamos. Es que
los últimos dos años de Osasuna
son complejos por diferentes razones,
pero son complejos y Budi
Mil se ha salido, es que para mí eso lo dice
todo. Fran Simón, Nau,
¿cómo veríais a Mauro
Alambari en un Betis
o un Villarreal? Entiendo en un Betis si se va
Johnny Cardoso, que puede ser un jugador de un
perfil más o menos parecido,
haciendo ese papel más destructor,
pero con llegada para fortalecer ambas medulares,
dice Fran Simón. ¿Cómo le verías en esos
dos equipos concretos y en ese nivel,
que es un nivel y medio
superior al Getafe, diría yo?
Es espectacular.
He nacido para jugar ahí.
Es que, vamos, lo veo.
Tampoco tiene
mucho más desarrollo. Tiene ese nivel.
Es cierto que creo que están muy
vinculadas a Getafe y que al final
es el... O sea, tú a Mauro Alambari
intentaría ficharlo, pues
cuando estaba en su etapa en Francia,
que es lo que harían Betis y Villarreal,
que es un jugador devaluado en ese sentido,
pero creo que ahora es
más complicado. Creo que van a priorizar
un futbolista que se pueda revalorizar
un poco más que Mauro Alambari. ¿Cómo valoras
esa ocasión fallada
ante el Real Madrid
y su impacto en tu equipo
Fantasy, Nauel?
Bueno, hasta los mejores fallan.
Muy bien, Nauel.
Elegante. Elegante.
Perdóname, Álex.
No, decía que
con el tema de
haciendo fútbol ficción, si Alambari
termina siguiendo al Betis, entiendo que
sería para jugar al lado de un Marroca, ¿no?
Sí, o de una Altimira.
O de una Altimira.
Que es su Luis Milla.
Sí, pero
no me terminaría de cuadrar
del todo en lo posicional. No sé si
me cuajan bien
Alambari.
A mí me gusta porque me parece un
jugador parecido a Cardoso, me parece un jugador que brilla más
en presiones, anticipando,
yendo, que estando,
ya sea defendiendo o atacando.
Y eso en el Betis lo hace muy bien, que es algo
que me flipa de Johnny Cardoso. A mí Johnny
me parece un jugador
tremendo. Qué pena que Johnny se lo vaya
a cargar el Tottenham Match.
O sea que esa operación...
Pero además es que la operación es maravísima
porque ha renovado a Johnny Cardoso con el Betis
y ha mantenido
la operación del Tottenham.
Pero a mí
Johnny Seymour me parece ese
jugador que destaca tanto en esas presiones,
en esos duels y tal, que si el Atlético Madrid
decidiese presionar, que sé que no lo va a hacer.
Pero sería el jugador al que ir.
O sea, ese Gabi Fernández,
que te va a ir adelante,
que te va a apretar, que te va a ganar
duelos. Y creo que eso es Mauro
Alambari en una versión creo que inferior
porque Johnny físicamente...
Ostras, es que es...
Creo que Mauro
es más porque es uruguayo
de escuela que por otra cosa.
Mauro no tiene cuerpo para hacer lo que hace.
Johnny Cardoso sí.
Mola una barbaridad.
Por cierto, si
Bordalás no viaja en un
monoplaza como se hace Pipi Estrada,
que nos lo encontramos en la Abueli y yo
al salir de la radio
en un vehículo de una sola plaza...
Cuidado con
mezclar a la pizarra con Pipi Estrada.
Que últimamente...
Ah, vale, ¿qué cojones tienes?
¿Cuánta gente os ha escrito
preguntando si era real lo de la última vez?
Que me han escrito
una barbaridad de familiares.
Me han escrito mis vecinos.
Creo que se fue un poco del hermano,
yo me he descojoneado y disfruto
lo subí yo.
Pero...
Está tan bien hecho, pero al mismo tiempo
yo les decía, pero tú me ves
tan buen profesional
para que se meta ese
audio y yo siga con mi
mierda del Girona.
Eso pasa en realidad.
Eso pasa en realidad
y, hombre, primero, bochorno gordo
y segundo...
pasan cosas ahí.
El dibujo de Garabatos está muy chulo.
Hacia espavientos.
Sí, hacia espavientos.
Bueno, aquí voy a decir que como creo que
Bordalas no viaja en un coche así,
si baja a Sevilla Bordalas
de Copiloto, Moura,
Arambari, creo que también estaría ventilado.
¿Sabes, Adri,
que este coche de Pipi
Estrada
cuando trabajábamos,
cuando Pipi Estrada tenía un programa
Movistar, era muy gracioso porque lo
se iba a los lunes, los martes, por ahí.
Entonces, en tres cantos
de Movistar hay muy poco espacio para
aparcar, lo que son cerca
de la tele. Y el tío
macho metía el coche,
¿sabes por qué? Porque es como un amotillo.
Es como un amotillo.
O sea, lo metía justo entre
donde estaba la salida del parking
de la gente que tenía pasta
y podía, bueno, cargo importante,
y podía tener el parking dentro y fuera.
Entonces lo metía ahí en un hueco.
Siempre hay que haber aparcado más.
Ese coche creo que lo puedes aparcar
en batería, en una calle normal.
Sí, sí, sí. Yo lo he visto aparcado así.
Claro.
Lo que habrá llamado a la
gente la atención es lo que ha dicho
Alex de cuando Pipi tenía un programa
Movistar. Sí, sí.
Ese programa
lo truco. Algún día
se escribirán cositas
sobre él. Fer Pulpillo,
¿creéis que volveremos
en algún momento? Fer Pulpillo sale
en todos los Q&A.
Muy buenas preguntas. Porque es gracioso.
Porque es gracioso el nombre, Fer Pulpillo.
Hombre, porque con este no hay
expecte trabadas.
Aquí es fácil.
Sobre raíles.
Pero no, dice, ¿creéis que volveremos
en algún momento a temporadas en la Liga
Española en las que la salvación se vaya a los
40 o más puntos como hace 15
o 20 años? No sé si 15 o
20 años, igual son 10.
Hace dos temporadas se fue por encima
de los 40.
La que estuvo metido el
Celta que le ganó el Barça, la del
Valencia que...
Por eso digo.
Pero es verdad que últimamente está
bastante más barato.
Creo que este año se va a volver a
encarecer. Creo que este año...
Yo creo que con 40 te salvas, pero claro.
Vamos a ver cómo
sobrepuntúan los equipos de abajo.
En todo caso, al final, esto siempre está
relacionado, chicos, con el hecho
de que los de arriba se dejen
puntos. Es que...
En estos años...
En estos años se están dejando más, ¿no?
Claro.
Pero yo creo que
este año, que está parecido a lo de años anteriores,
más o menos, creo que
este año el problema ha sido la clase media
alta, que bueno, es que ahora mismo la pelea
por Europa es una pelea
puños. Nadie tiene
ni una navajilla
para sacar ahí. Entonces,
creo que eso contribuye mucho a que
de repente el Mallorca se esté
jugando Europa, juegue en casa
en Son Móz ante el Léganés y
empate. O sea...
Esto no es, entre comillas, lo normal.
Y creo que
hace unos años los equipos de arriba
se iban a tantísimos puntos que se los quitaban al resto.
Ahora que los de arriba no están
tan fuertes, pues si se
debilita un poco la clase media alta
y los de abajo hacen un buen trabajo,
pues sí que se puede ir allí.
Sí, a ver, también
es verdad que llevamos varias temporadas
con algún equipo
que
está muy por debajo del nivel
de primera. El Ballaudí
de este año, lo de Granada y Almería
la temporada pasada,
el Cádiz del Levante en el
Limbo varios años por nivel de plantilla,
estaba muy por debajo de lo que es primera.
Yo el otro día,
creo que lo hablábamos, Álex, en el grupo de WhatsApp
que tenemos con el Yogo, sobre
el tema este de
los 18 equipos en una competición
y demás, que más allá del calendario,
que esto lo debatíamos también ayer
en la pizarra, que yo creo que si quitasen dos
equipos en Liga, esos
espacios en el calendario ya los ocuparía otra competición
porque esto funciona así.
Pero lo que se comenta poco es
que, entre
que el fútbol español
ha perdido algo de capacidad económica,
que han aparecido
nuevos mercados que se llevan a nuevos talentos,
que la MLS va
por otro tipo de perfil,
que Brasil es capaz de retener
un poco más talento, igual que México.
Al final, hace que el talento
esté de nuevo,
no tanto como antes de Ale i Bosman, pero de nuevo,
muy disgregado.
Encima, las plantillas de lo grande son
tan amplias por los cinco cambios,
que hace que al final los buenos jugadores
estén en muchos
mercados diferentes
y eso hace que el 20º, el 19º
y el 18º de la Liga
tengan menos calidad.
Al final, no hay tanto buen jugador
para tanto equipo. No sé si me explico.
Y esto, chicos, yo creo que se está viendo
muy claro en Inglaterra, que no hay
falta de dinero, pero lo que sí
que se ve es falta de calidad
a raudales. O sea que el Leicester,
el Southampton y el
Eastwich han descendido como
descendieron el año pasado también. Los equipos
que habían ascendido nuevamente a la Premier League
pues te habla claramente de lo que está ocurriendo.
Claro, dice, por ejemplo,
citaban en Sky Sports
¿Qué tienen que hacer los clubes
de Alicia Rojkin? Poner más esfuerzo.
Y entonces salía el meme de Hank
Scorpio de los Simpson diciendo
cómo no se me había ocurrido
poner más esfuerzo
para salvarme.
La noticia de Ken Leeds
se puede caer en el Farque porque...
¡Ostras!
¡Los pulgares!
¡Me he bloqueado!
Igual es por otro efecto.
¡No! ¡Ah!
¿Qué hago?
346 minutos más tarde.
Ya está arreglado.
Ya está arreglado. Perdonadme.
Estábamos diciendo. Ibas a hablar, Nahuel,
sobre el tema de las temporadas.
Creo que cada vez hay más diferencia
entre la Premier y la Segunda. Lo estamos viendo en la Premier.
Pasa también en España.
Pasa en Alemania.
Y el tema de Ken Leeds, que ha subido esta semana,
está dejando rumores de que se puede cargar
el entrenador a Daniel Farque.
Porque es que da la sensación de que...
Bueno, en el club tiene la sensación de que no ha estado bien
cuando ha tenido equipos en Premier.
Es que te lo dice todo. Es que hay una psicosis...
Suena a Mourinho, ¿eh?
Suena a Mourinho.
Bueno, pero Mourinho...
Yo hay otro rumor de Mourinho que me gusta
un poco más. ¿Cuál?
Portugal. Por cierto,
la selección...
¿Por qué?
Espera, ¿y Roberto Martínez?
Bueno, dos seleccionadores creo que no tienen ninguna selección.
Bueno, pero puede ser.
Pero, a ver, imbécil.
Puede ser porque Roberto Martínez se quiera ir.
O porque... No, no.
Lo quieren ir. Vale, vale.
Bueno, el tema es que ha sacado
la EBC
un documental que se puede ver...
Hay un poquito...
Si das dos clics, lo ves.
Si das dos clics, lo ves, exactamente.
How to win a Champions League.
Sí, muy bueno.
Hay José Mourinho, muy bueno.
Vale. Octava pregunta, penúltima.
Luis Rodríguez...
No se estaba escuchando, necesito que os callaráis
y vamos a la siguiente pregunta.
Vale. No, no, no.
Es que vale, o sea, ¿qué quieres que te diga?
Vale. Vale, punto.
Luis Rodríguez Rego.
Hola. A ver si os mojáis de verdad.
¿Por qué ningún árbitro de nuestra Liga
ha sido designado para arbitrar
en el futuro mundial de clubes?
Yo creo que es muy evidente.
Y ya haremos alguna cosita al final de la temporada.
Es que no hay nivel.
Y el nivel de arbitraje en la Liga es
tremendamente bajo.
Pero además han llevado a los de VAR,
que me parecen que tampoco ganan.
No, no, no. De hecho, igual dan menos.
Pero es obvio que
más allá de protocolos,
de temas de VAR
y de diferentes cuestiones que hemos venido analizando,
Adri, Alex, Nau,
hay un punto ya de deterioro
en el nivel arbitral,
muy serio, y que hace que
en cada jornada haya cosas...
Ostras, son fallos estrepitosos.
Nosotros no hablamos, insisto,
de ejemplos concretos,
no vamos a estar permanentemente
conjugadas, pero
si tú analizas la globalidad
con todo el fútbol que vemos,
ostras, es que está mal la cosa.
Eso se nota, o se deja ver también
cuando hay cuestiones de este tipo,
Eurocopas, Mundial de Champions, Mundial de clubes,
donde no hay arbitros españoles.
Sí, hay poco nivel
arbitral y creo que
el sistema visto desde fuera
tampoco ayuda demasiado
a designar
en este tipo de competiciones.
Así que creo que esto llega
también fuera, lo que vemos aquí
habitualmente se llama la Liga de VAR.
Y es que es un tipo de
competiciones que no tenemos representantes
españoles en este tipo de competiciones.
Yo entiendo que es lo que ocurre,
que deben ver el nivel
más palpable,
el nivel de arbitraje, pero también el nivel
de manos,
politiqueo, etcétera,
que hay en el fútbol español.
Entiendo que debe ocurrir
en todos igual, pero creo que en España
ocurre de manera muy exagerada.
Y bueno, pues obviamente,
claro, solo que
el jefe de los arbitros a nivel europeo
debe decir, eh, eh, eh, cuidado.
A ver, ¿qué pasa en España ahora?
En teoría...
La inestabilidad con el tema
del CTA, que no se sabe quién va a estar
la próxima temporada...
De la Federación.
Yo creo que todo eso influye mucho más que el nivel.
Viendo experiencias anteriores,
así que creo que tiene más de política que otra cosa.
Sí, puede ser, porque tampoco es que
seguro preguntas por los
antecedentes, pero no es que
seguro preguntas por los anteriores
árbitros internacionales, y alguno puede
generar alguno de consenso, pero
los internacionales suelen pitar los grandes partidos
y los grandes partidos nunca generan
consenso. Así que también puede haber
mucho de eso, pero sí que creo que
es preocupante el nivel del arbitraje
en España. Creo que muy derivado,
insisto, del protocolo y de
la falta de empoderamiento
de los árbitros de campo que se están
dejando ir, están dejando de pitar.
Básicamente. Y es lo más...
Es lo peor que puede tener un árbitro, ser covarde.
Y es lo que está pasando ahora mismo.
Última cuestión.
Oye, por cierto,
tenía la duda, Miguel,
el 11 de octubre
es el Día Internacional del Árbitro.
Digo, es que
has hablado de empoderar
a los árbitros y de pensar en ellos,
tienen su propio Día Internacional.
Día Internacional del Árbitro... Menos mal
que no fue un mes antes,
porque...
El Día Internacional...
Es que normal
cerrar el canal.
He dicho que menos mal, joder.
Era una mala efeméride.
El Día Internacional lo inventaron los
community managers, para tener algo que...
Sí, un poquito de trabajo, eh.
Un poquito...
Bueno, mejor haciendo esas cosas que haciendo
otras, Álex. Manuel Jesús
Mariscal Contrer,
entiendo yo que ya no quedan más
caracteres, equipos
cuyos suplentes aportan más
y aportan menos en la Liga.
Comenzamos por los que aportan más, chicos,
que suplentes,
también, evidentemente, estamos hablando aquí de la dirección
de campo de los entrenadores,
creéis que aportan más, que dan más a los equipos,
que dan más puntos, que cambian más
partidos, Álex...
Eh...
Hombre, yo creo que hay, sí, Estuani y yo
creo que es uno muy claro, por ejemplo,
porque estamos viendo mucho. A ver...
O sea, el Girona, quiero decir, como equipo.
No sé yo si el Girona como equipo
está cambiando muchas cosas, pero es verdad que
esto va a ir.
Depende si Estuani es titular o no.
Claro, si Estuani es titular, los suplentes no cambian.
Si Estuani es suplente, los suplentes cambian.
Eso es verdad, eso es verdad.
Pero, por ejemplo, el Atleti Club,
la rotación de Atleti Club esta temporada
está aportando...
Es tremendo. Sí, porque aquí...
Y es verdad que Jaló, por ejemplo, sí que es verdad que
de las expectativas que teníamos
de diciembre de temporada no las ha cumplido.
Esto igual tiene que ver más con la plantilla
porque es verdad, Zadri, que lo que están
cumpliendo sobre todo es
en las rotaciones. O sea, quiero decir
eh...
Luego hay también suplentes que ganan partidos, pero que tienen
un punto de trampa, como cuando entraron desde el banquillo
Sanchez, Zanadi...
Creo que Ruy de Galarreta
también hace dos, tres partidos de
Atleti Club. Pero ahí las rotaciones
están aportando mucho. Yo en cambio es directo,
aunque se haya caído,
creo que hay que hablar del Atlético de Madrid, de Diego Pablo Simeone.
O sea, al final el short-loss más correa
en su momento coque.
Lino, que llegó a aportar en varios partidos,
aunque ahora no lo parezca.
Ostras, creo que el Atlético
de Madrid sacó muchos puntos,
muchísimos puntos así. De hecho, estaba viendo aquí
en Transfer Market que tienen un poquito
las participaciones
en goles de los
suplentes, ¿vale?
El líder es
Diego Pablo Simeone, o el Atlético de Madrid,
con 34 segundos.
Mira que eres el tercero.
Claudio Giralde,
pero segundo es Hansi Flick
y tercero es Claudio Giralde,
empatado con Michel.
El caso del Celta
creo que es bastante obvio porque con...
es que rota tanto
también. Giralde es imposible.
Es un poco Atlético ahí.
Se cachondea un poquito el tema
por la acumulación de partidos
que venía ahora y bueno, si roto de normal,
imaginaos si jugamos cada tres días.
Pero, pero...
¿Le llamaría a rotar a lo que hace Giralde?
Porque para mí lo que hace es...
No, le cambia la cara al equipo.
Va buscando lo que más se adapte.
Pero ahora se hace de que entre quién entre, que el equipo
compite. Entonces...
A mí me parece brutal porque creo que es el entrenador
de todos los de la liga, aunque el
Celta tiene su forma de competir,
pero es el equipo de todos de la liga
que condiciona más el once
y matices de su estrategia operativa,
planteamiento operativo como llaman los entrenadores,
al rival. O sea, me parece, de verdad.
Es muy claro.
Con una plantilla con creo que son 18 fichas
del primer equipo, más luego chavales
que el año pasado
estaban en el Celta Fortuna, me parece que tiene
un mérito tremendo. Y en hecho
parece una bala competitiva esa pelea, eh.
Porque al final, yo creo que eso, o sea,
Suna no lo tiene, Getafe no lo tiene,
El Rayo...
depende del día.
El Mallorca, yo creo que
se le han caído esos fichajes de profundidad.
No lo tiene porque no está Giralde
o no lo tiene
por la plantilla. Porque claro, es que Giralde
le da un valor a determinados jugadores,
Pablo Duran y
Alfón, a comienzo de temporada,
eran más o menos
que los suplentes número 17 y 18
en Osasuna o en el Mallorca. No sé si me...
si sabes por dónde voy. Es que lo optimiza mucho.
Pero es que yo creo que el Celta
tiene una cantera que no tiene Osasuna,
que no tiene el Mallorca, que no tiene el Mallorca y el Vallecano.
Osasuna la tiene.
Para qué...
Tiene un aspirador acerca.
La tiene. Tajonar la tiene.
Bueno, sí, sí.
Tenerla no la tiene.
No, tenerla la tiene.
Otra cosa es que no produzca tanto.
Pero es que aparece el diezmo,
aparece por ahí...
El señor feudal, eh.
Me voy a llevar a tu mediapunta.
Claro, claro, claro.
Pero bueno, me entendéis, ¿no? Que creo que el Celta
sabe que tiene esta gran virtud
y creo que por cómo se ha montado el proyecto
se va a aprovecharla.
En esta clasificación, Adri,
no sé si te sorprende,
porque está...
Simeone, es que lo digo porque lo tiene Transformer que Concentradors.
Simeone 34.
Flick 27. Que en lo de Flick hay que
hablarlo de... Vale, lo de Flick es que lo decimos
con todo. O sea, es que el Barça está arriba
en todo. Lo decíamos con el balón parado.
¿Needita el Barça el balón parado?
Como quien dice, no. Pero es que sigue siendo el que más ha marcado.
Lo suplente, más de lo mismo.
Es una barbaridad.
Ferran es un caso absolutamente
paradigmático y creo que
es uno de los grandes suplentes
de la Liga. Se ha sumado mucho en ese
sentido. Luego están Michel y Giralde
como digo con 17.
Valverde está con 19, solo que empatado
en goles y por eso aparece quinto, porque en goles
directos son 12-12-12.
Michel, Giralde, Valverde. Y en sexta
posición, que es lo que tenía planteado Adri,
aparece el Villarreal con Marcelino.
10 goles, 15 participaciones
de gol. Me llama la atención
porque yo creía que el Villarreal iba a estar más arriba
porque es un equipo también que tiene
siempre cinco cambios
tremendamente hábiles.
Tú vas al banquillo,
ves minuto 50 y dices
que el Villarreal puede cambiar el encuentro porque
te mete a un punto diferente,
a un extremo diferente, a un centro campista
diferente. Muchas veces parejo ha sido suplente.
Te puedo cambiar el perfil de los laterales.
Hasta la lesión de Buchanan.
Estaban entre Buchanan y Jeremy y Pino.
Lo de revolucionar el partido, lo de PP
en punta también.
No me sorprende,
pero ¿dónde está Carlo Ancelotti en esa clasificación?
Con cuatro goles y
diez participaciones en goles.
Decimo quinto.
Porque claro, la pregunta
era los que aportan más, los que aportan
menos. Aquí, por debajo
de Ancelotti, hay muchos,
evidentemente.
Bueno,
está en Ecuador, casi.
15 de 27.
Claro, están todos los que han...
Claro, de hecho...
Igual están
Diego Coca, Álvaro Rubio.
De hecho, mira, mira, mira.
Déjame, déjame, déjame.
Carrión, Carrión.
Está el último, Diego Coca,
luego Caparrós, Rubén
Urilla, Rubén Baraja...
Rubén Uriano, mira, mira.
Rubén Baraja,
Pablo Petzolano,
Álvaro Rubio,
Carrión. ¿Me sorprende ver
tan abajo a Yago Barrazate en el Mallorca?
¿Me sorprende ver tan abajo? El Mallorca no tiene banquillo.
El Mallorca no tiene banquillo. Tienen 10 o 6
jugadores y cuando selecciona alguno le cuesta mucho.
Vicente Moreno con Osasuna,
García Pimienta, que esto se lo criticaban
mucho, de la plantilla de Sevilla, ya lo hemos dicho.
Carlos Corberán, que, hombre, va escalando.
No estaría aquí si hubiese jugado toda la temporada.
Chacho Cudet, caso parecido
al de Carlos Corberán.
Y Carlo Ancelotti,
de los entrenadores que han entrenado
todos los partidos de la Liga,
por hacer esa clasificación,
solo Yago Barrazate y
Vicente Moreno están por detrás de
Carlo Ancelotti, cuatro goles marcados,
sus suplentes, 10 participaciones
de gol, teniendo a jugadores como
Brahim, teniendo a jugadores
como Hendrik, teniendo a veces
suplentes como
Rodrigo el último día en Getafe,
o Bellingham, que a veces son suplentes.
Y hay cierto sentido, porque al final
le hacen los cambios muy tarde,
a mí no se me ocurre no hablar de Ancelotti,
y que luego también,
a ver, al final el Real Madrid
es un equipo que no tiene
que revolucionar partidos habitualmente,
que no llega perdiendo el tramo final, que es cierto,
que Atlético y Barça están arriba,
y vamos, yo creo
de una manera muy merecida, pero al final juntas
todo y le encuentras cierto sentido
a aquel lado. Y yo también le encuentro
el sentido, que esto lo comentamos al principio de temporada,
el año pasado,
esto es por la forma de gestionar también de Ancelotti,
pero pasaría con la mayoría de entrenadores,
el año pasado
Ancelotti iba a dos
cambios, no los iba a hacer, no iba a quitar nunca
ni a Vinicius, ni a Bellingham,
si tienes que ganar un partido,
ni de coña, quitas a Vinicius y a Bellingham, y además
yo estoy de acuerdo, salvo que
Vinicius esté tan mal como algún partido que ha estado mal
esta temporada. En general,
Miguel, no sé si lo tienes a mano,
en la comparativa con el año anterior,
lo mira ahora, lo mira ahora
este año ya no puedes quitar
ni a Vinicius, ni a Bellingham, ni a Mbappé.
Entonces claro, encima no tienes un suplente como José Lu, que encarnava ese rol que hemos dicho de Sorloz, de Ferran y demás,
y te quedas con eso. El año pasado el líder fue
Chávi,
está ordenado en goles, Chávi,
Michel Simeone,
y Carlos Ancelotti estaba
en participaciones en goles estaba primero
en Girona,
pero lo de la participación en goles hay que tenerlo cuidado,
que tras Fermar que cuenta penalti provocado.
Penaltis forzados, sí. Pues mira,
Carlos Ancelotti está muy parecido este año al pasado,
fueron cinco goles directos,
12 participaciones de gol,
decimocuarto, este año está bastante parecido,
algo peor. Fíjate en los goles con quien está empatado, con Francisco,
o con Kike Salcheflores,
con Marcelino,
y está uno de Pepe Meli.
Mira, y en este dato,
esto mola, eh, os lo pondremos en pantalla,
o bueno, lo estaréis viendo en pantalla,
evidentemente, pero Claudio Giralde
con diez partidos,
estaba al lado de Rafa Benítez con
28 y ya estaba décimo.
Habiendo entrenado una cuarta parte,
Giralde ya estaba ahí.
Me parece que
ya venimos hablando de Giralde,
el otro día hicimos un...
tuvimos una buena charleta
al final
sobre el Celta,
la gestión del jugador
y un poquito lo que está haciendo
a partir de la declaración de
Borja Elésez, la tuvimos con Javier Mello,
pizarra de pro y también miembro de
Atlético Estad, jugador del Andratz.
Y algún día tendremos...
yo estoy esperando a que el Celta
se meta en Europa para no agafar,
porque mira, creo que el celtismo,
lo de meter a estar Celta abajo,
nos lo ha perdonado. Si hacemos un análisis
del Celta ahora y el Celta
empieza a caerse como se cayó
en febrero...
Ahora lo que tienes que
potenciar son los análisis de equipos
que la están pasando mal, como el que
hiciste ahí del Girona, para ver si
funcione contra Gafé.
Bueno, como insistimos,
no hacemos spoilers, no vamos a decir
cómo quedó anoche el Girona
en Butarque, solo tengo que decir
que estuviste muy bien
Ales en los comentarios. Qué placer
comentar contigo. No también
como tú, Miguel, no también como tú, Macho.
Qué bien lo hiciste.
Gracias, Ales.
Bueno, gracias, Pizarritas.
Hasta aquí este Q&A.
Veo a Nahuel Miranda
buscando cositas, creo que sigue buscando
jugadores como Joan García.
Estuve buscando la hora, a ver si...
¿La hora?
¿Has metido en el parque? No, mira.
Mira, solo, y eso que ha habido
un error en la cámara, solo llevamos 55
minutos, así que aparte
de agradecerle a los Pizarritas
sus preguntas, sus likes, sus
comentarios y demás,
pediros perdón,
pediros perdón por no llegar a la hora.
No volverás a su... No, no, no, estás malcriando la audiencia.
No volverá a su... Estás malcriando la audiencia.
No, no, no. El próximo para compensar.
Oregoso.
No.